Paul before we talk about the story I
want to talk about the period about what
was happening in 1950 post-war pre
ready-to-wear designer fashion why is
this period so good for this kind of
story I'm glad you asked well just after
the war there were there were two places
where fashion was was going strong Paris
and London but Paris was really
excelling because a lot of the designers
it kind of laid low and right after the
war they were all to kind of emerge
immediately and come up with some pretty
great stuff obviously the list is long
this stuff the dresses that we all kind
of know if you've ever seen a picture of
a great dress in history or D or
Balenciaga going further into G Vaughn
she and stuff like that but the those
were great designers but the people that
made the dresses were were there they
were available to them in London there
was a little bit of a stutter star after
the war I mean rationing was still there
even though maybe the designers weren't
beholden to that kind of stuff that they
were really trying to the government
always trying to sort of push to sort of
make certain walls and fabrics and stuff
like that so that they could kind of get
a foothold back into the industry and
that's where our guy is and we decided
to set our story in 55 which is just
after rationing and just sort of far
enough away from the war that you could
kind of have the hangover of it a little
bit still but not have to really address
it too much because our story was
occupied with something else do you
start thinking about this romance from
the very beginning and then it becomes a
fashion designer or do they become one
of the same very early on no that's the
order it was a love story in a
relationship movie first and the nature
of their relationship was obvious to me
that it was a man of kyuf of great
fussiness
of seeing singular and kind of
self-obsessed and possessed and that
what would happen when his life is
interrupted by love in a way that kind
of
that makes her a good dramatic story so
we were in search of a job for this
character and all signs started pointing
towards making it a fashion designer
because it could give us some good you
know good costumes good production so
mark you have worked with Paul on pretty
much everything he's ever done correct
this seems like an assignment that is
both gratifying and terrifying because
we're at a composer he is asking you to
write a symphony and this character is
gonna be a great musician as the
designer you're gonna have to come up
with a wardrobe and designs that justify
his renown so what is your starting
point for the work that this character
is going to do where do you start
deciding what his style is going to be
you know I think at first we I came over
and looked at the things that you'd been
looking at and kind of what captured
your imagination and luckily I had a
script to work with to and figured out
what the major sort of beat gowns or
outfits would be and and then you know
he's got things that he's interested in
and I'll go away and do some more
research and come back and say well how
about this or how about if we approach
this a certain way and and then put that
together in a visual book and and yes
know maybe and then I think we took it
to Daniel to look at as well in New York
at that point right we realized pretty
early on that it wouldn't be the
traditional thing where Marc and I might
be collaborating on the costumes that
there was a triangle that we have Daniel
playing a costume designer he's gonna
have something to say about it right so
it was a kind of so we we have we had to
kind of find a way for the three of us
to work which actually ended up being
really easy but it was just you know you
look at all these dresses and the
inspirations and the inspirations might
have been initially like a Balenciaga
but that was my very sculpted stuff
Charles James really sculpted stuff and
the one thing I remember us saying early
on was like right we're not making a
movie about the world's greatest fashion
designer you know because we wanted it
to be very very English and
does that mean so that means tweeds and
that means sort of the the creative the
creative inspirations that are coming
out of this man and Daniel could sort of
start to fill in those inspirations and
and Mark would sort of then interpret
them and bring them to life so at what
point do you decide it's not going to be
chic [ __ ] chic I mean I know but it's an
important point in the in the story and
what how would you define that in your
conversations how do you define [ __ ]
chic what is that not going to be in
terms of what he is not going to do as a
designer we weren't allowed to say the
word chic so we did it but it's also
it's you know I love the idea that sort
of films kind of unfold you know every
decision influences the next decision
kind of and I thought that we went on
this weird road of looking at
inspiration and then seeing what we had
or finding a new garment or something to
be inspired by and then including Daniel
in on the conversation and look at this
fabric and what did he think of things
and so it really there's no seed of any
one garment it's a lot of interesting
influence but I think the other thing
that started to happen is that you can
have all these ideas and maybe you're
pulling inspiration from historical
that's one thing and then it starts to
get even more because maybe you're
thinking about stealing or combining two
different dresses that you see
historically when it starts to get more
interesting is when we could have had an
atelier to build these costumes and
you're actually then making up ideas
based on these fabrics or laces and then
to take it a step further it became even
more interesting when the casting has
happened because then you're sort of
you're also shaping ideas to the women
who are going to wear these dresses
because the dresses were great but when
they're laying on the floor that it's
just like a pile of fabric but when it's
on somebody it really becomes a dress
and so once we started once we had Vicky
and there was her shape everything
everything just comes out of like oh
this is a great dress or that's
historical or whatever it was and it
starts to become slowly its own creation
which is
that's when it really started to get
really fun where did you find Vicky and
what did you need for your actor to play
all my we found her in a tea shop in the
north of London no we found Daniel and I
fantasized about what we wanted and what
we wanted was somebody a European sort
of Eastern European perhaps somewhere
from over there
certainly an immigrant to England at
that time I started keeping my eyes open
and I saw a movie that Vicki made called
the chambermaid which I really enjoyed
and then in the traditional way of
casting Cassandra kulakundis our casting
director asked sort of women between a
certain age and a certain background to
audition and then one of the very early
on a tape came in that was Vicki's and
it was like in a classic case of stop
looking you know stop looking that's
that just she seemed to be so perfect
and I don't think we realized just how
perfect it was she was perfect in the
way that she looked in the way that
these words came out of her and a kind
of determination she's here so I
shouldn't say a lot of it it's okay but
and then to meet her was kind of further
proof that she's just as strong-willed
determined bossy and all the rest is all
and that probably comes in handy when
you're acting opposite somebody like
Daniel who's gonna be very forceful in
his performance I don't there's maybe a
better word for it but you describe what
it was like acting opposite Daniel and
how much of a Alma was part of you
acting opposite this very strong-willed
actor it was a it was a talent to work
with him of course and you know I think
it's really difficult for me to to give
the right answer because I was only
trying to to react you know because
obviously he was preparing so well in
such a long time and I
I didn't prepare I I prepared a little
bit on my side but I couldn't rehearse
or anything and so I decided to take it
from the place that was left for me
which was no place you know what I mean
so I tried to be open and completely not
really know what I'm doing you know to
rely on my instinct and that's what I
did so I don't really know how it was to
to work with him because I was with
Reynolds the whole time it was always
been ants and I was just trying to react
here when you come on Dylan how far in
the process is the film and at what
point are you starting to hear Johnny's
music as well Paul and I talk and hang
out before shooting but at when shooting
starts I start and looking at stuff and
talking to Paul and kind of putting
things together and making sure
everybody has what they need so I was in
London for the shoot
Johnny's we I mean I when I walked in i
think we had 20 queues that Paul's you
know Johnny did a new thing I got this
morning and he'll just send it and it's
incredibly inspiring because he's Johnny
watches dailies - we give him sets of
dailies as we go but I think it's late
in the in the process when he starts to
sort of compose to picture if he ever
does it's more from talking to Paul from
knowing the script and from feeling and
I think he does stuff bouncing off Paul
that we end up with a whole treasure
trove of stuff that you know immediately
several genius things pop to the top and
whoa this is great this is great the
kind of theme for the movie the riddle
piano thing is we came early on in its
initial form and I love that way of
working with music actually that it
doesn't get sort of nailed to picture
that it's a song that it's a feeling
from the composer like a performance
from an actor like words from the writer
you've got this other thing that
you know sometimes it knows where it
wants to go but other times we're just
trying it out let's try this here let's
try that there and it's a great
malleable back and forth where notes go
to him and keys come back and we just
bat it back and forth I want to talk
about some specifics about the design
their seamstresses who are building some
of these clothes
look like to me real seamstresses did
you actually cast people who had built
clothes and knew the way in which that
style of clothing would have been made
by hand yeah that's right it's a
combination naana an biddy if you
remember the two older women there's
that there they we met them at the VNA
they're volunteers there but they worked
for hardy Amy's 60s maybe 60s 50s late
50s 60s and then and they were super
helpful and then so charismatic that we
also gave them sizable roles and then
all the background as a combination of
actresses with sewing experience you
know you have like resumes and at the
bottom is like horseback riding and
anything like sewing and so it was we
had them and that they but in the
foreground were a real set of hands who
were actually some of the source who
made the actual costumes I mean so
they're building costumes on camera
they're well worse than that they're
building costumes the night before until
like five o'clock in the morning
finishing it coming to the set at 8:00
with no sleep and then being asked to do
it again for the camera rip it apart and
do it again for the camera so yeah and
yeah that's why they look so tired
thank you for bringing us your film
Thank You Johnny